welcome to horace hobbies the channel
where we discussed the latest tech news
and delve into newest tech products
today we're taking a look at the truth
behind the release date of the gtx 1180
and why it may not even exist but before
we delve into that make sure hit that
subscribe button if you guys would like
to stay updated with the latest tech
news related to gaming and pcs so as you
guys already know the gtx 1180 has been
dissipated for quite a while now and
there have been very many leaks and
rumors as well as many release dates
floating around there so what tomorrow's
release dates is actually true and does
the G takes 1180 even have a release day
in the first place well gamer mail
suggested that the gtx 1180 would
release on july 30th and this actually
matches up with a bunch of other leaks
so let's take a look at this scenario
first this actually makes a lot of sense
considering that SK Hynix coolest a
memory producer for Nvidia we're
planning to start there gdb are six
memory production in June so a July
launch from Nvidia would make sense also
it has been over two years since the 10
series came out and it's about time for
a refresh and on top of this if they
start releasing now that it'll give in
video plenty of time to get all the GPU
skews out before the holiday season so
they can take advantage of the extra
sales that happened during the holiday
season of 2018 so pretty much everything
lines up for this release date except
for there is one huge issue and a huge
issue is that this release date is less
than four weeks away and we haven't
heard a single thing from Nvidia about
the 1100 series itself in fact the only
thing we've heard from Nvidia is that
the gtx 1100 series wasn't coming for a
long time so why is this well here's
what I speculate I do believe that
Nvidia originally planned a July 30th
launch for the GTX 1180 but once they
saw how much excess inventory of the 10
series they still have they probably
pushed it back and this would explain
all the rumors that originally came up
for the gtx lemonade
coming out at the end of july if you
guys didn't already know
nvidia sales aren't doing
and they are down by about 20% which is
quite a big difference and on top of
this a Taiwanese om actually returned
300,000 GPUs backed Nvidia not because
there were any defect or anything but
just because they didn't think they
could sell that many GPUs to make things
even worse Nvidia apparently has over 1
million GPUs of the 10 series just lying
in their warehouses and especially with
the hype around in the GTX of 1100
series these all the 10 series GPUs
don't seem to be moving anywhere as a
result Nvidia will most likely focus on
getting rid of this excess inventory
before they even think about releasing
the gtx 1100 series and as a result the
gtx 1180 may not even have a set release
date and it is just going to come out
once Invidia is satisfied with their
inventory levels of the 10 series the
good thing is is that nvidia is really
pushing to get rid of these GPUs by
offering really good deals and discounts
this month we are supposed to be seeing
over 20% discounts on GPUs across the
board so that will really help increase
in video sales and get rid of all this
extra inventory and bring down the
inventory to a much more reasonable
level in a short period of time so
that's all cool now but then when
exactly is the gtx 1180 actually going
to come out well first of all I really
respect what gamer MELD has to say and I
think he's a very credible source and
the release date that he suggested may
indeed be correct and I really do hope
that he is correct because the earlier
these GPUs come out the better for
everyone but at the same time I do
believe that some events could have
taken place after gamer MELD heard that
news which could have led to a postpone
of the gtx 1180 release and with nvidia
not saying anything July 30th just seems
too early for me so here's what I think
is going to happen it was rumored that
Nvidia was going to be revealing their
new 1100 series at the hot chips
conference in August
considering that Nvidia will most likely
be releasing all the SKUs of their GPUs
throughout
Tambor and October and this way in video
would still be able to catch the holiday
season of 2018 so they have all the
booster tails and they be able to have a
full solid two months to get rid of all
the extra inventory they have of the ten
series so in my opinion I just feel like
this just makes more sense and this is
what's going to happen as a result I
don't think that Nvidia currently has a
set release date in mind and right now
it is just set to come sometime in
September after the hot chips conference
in August finally yes I do think all of
you guys should just wait for the 1100
series instead of buying a discount at
NZ right now Vicky's again it'll offer
you much more performance for the same
price and NVIDIA is pretty much ready
and NVIDIA is pretty much ready to
launch the 1100 series and they are just
facing a minor setback that they're
having to deal with right now I
definitely believe that video will
launch the 1100 series before the
holiday season of this year because I
really doubt they would want to miss out
on all those tales as a result I think
all of you guys should wait till the
holiday season this year and get a new
11 or series GPU at a really good
discounted price but that's just what I
think what do you guys think do you guys
think that the GTX 11e is going to come
out on July 30th or in September make
sure to comment down below what you guys
think because I do read all my comments
and I'm curious as to what you guys
think so make sure to post your thoughts
also if you guys like this video then
make sure to drop a like and hit that
subscribe button if you guys like to see
more videos just like this one but until
next time bye
[Music]